Now, so far,
any time I talk about overflow,
I indicated that we're writing.
That we're storing data in
some part of memory, and
we keep going beyond the limit
where we should stop.
And so, the overflow is
the result of writing stuff.
Overflows don't just have to be
associated with writing data.
Overflows could also
happen because we read.
The whole idea here is that overflow
is because we do too much of something.
We keep writing beyond the limit, so we
write more than what we're supposed to.
What if you read too much?
Let's say a variable has 12 bytes but
you asked to read 100 bytes.
What the read is going to do is it's
going to keep going beyond the variable
and it's going to go on to the next
one and the one after that, and
things like that.
So wherever in memory you have
that variable that you're reading,
if you go beyond that, you're
going to get into other variables.
Now, there is a fairly well-known
vulnerability in the open SSL code
which is used to secure all kinds
of online transactions, and
secure communications, and so on.
It was called
the Heartbleed Vulnerability.
Actually, it was an overflow
related vulnerability.
But it wasn't writing into the stack
beyond the memory that we had allocated
for the variable into
which we are writing.
It was actually a read
overflow vulnerability.
Actually, this OpenSSL Heartbleed did,
is that it kept reading beyond the
variable that you're supposed to read.
And there was some juicy stuff
beyond that to do with keys and
things like that.
So if you read too much, you're going to
get additional data beyond what's really
should be in this variable
that you're trying to read.
And so, the additional data that
you got could be used to figure out
sensitive keys and things like that,
and that's what the vulnerability was.
But the vulnerability comes from
the fact that we're reading beyond
the variable that the code
was supposed to access.
As a result, the overflow
occurs while you are reading.
You go beyond the boundary of
the variable and keep going.
So that's called
a Read-only Buffer Overflow, and
the example that we just discussed
the is the Heartbleed Vulnerability that
occurred because of that.
Buffer overflows don't
have to be on attack only.
They can happen on the heap, and
buffer overflows don't have to be just
when you write,
they can also happen when you read.
It's just going beyond the boundary
where you should stop.
You don't do that, that's the overflow.
If you're reading some data,
then it's read-only buffer overflow.